yeah so there's been a very big moment
in my life recently I just moved to New
York City a couple months ago yeah it's
truly been just okay new New York is a
place I know um I realized pretty early
on moving there that because I'm a
pretty safe looking black man that
strangers love talking to me I was on
the train talking to this one woman
she's having small talk and she asked me
where was I from originally and I was
like oh the south side of Chicago can I
get some posing so again she replied oh
my god I'm so sorry
and I was like what a bitch you have
strong opinions and then she leaned in
closer and she asked have you ever been
shot I replied first of all have you no
couth white devil how would you feel if
I asked where are your lips then second
of all no I have not been shot and I
think that's a very shitty stereotype
that perpetuates the idea the Chicago is
a very violent place so I want to say
right now in front of all of you that
yes I was born and raised on the south
side of Chicago and I have never been
shot thank you so much I'm a hero I have
been shot at though but they missed
every time
Oh jack is coming up she's gonna get
real okay my feelings about Chicago are
pretty unique like as a black man I love
Chicago I would defend it to the end as
a gay man a place could suck a bag of
dicks and die if it is trash she could
burn to the ground again and it's funny
cuz I think Chicago's the reason why I'm
as gay as I am like was I born gay maybe
I came out of my mother's vagina and I
was like oh my god yeah what is this
then the doctor smacked my ass and I was
like I realize I was gay at a pretty
young age but I also realized that
within certain environments it was not
okay to be gay so I was in the closet
for quite a bit of time now remember the
exact moment my gayness was solidified I
was dating this girl named Raven I hope
she's not here and I it was the day that
I lost my virginity to much her Gran's
house cuz we're edgy and we got there
took her clothes put on some music I
asked if it could be Celine Dion she
said No then I started to smash that
can't and it was great it was gone wow
she was looking at me I was looking at a
picture of her father
and she was like let's raise the stakes
and I was like please don't
and she was like hey go down on me I was
like for sure I love a challenge
so I go down there ladies this is
complex
better not only know what I was doing so
I just started experimenting so I
slapped it a little bit blue inside of
it can't get the Rings to see how it was
she's like nah no silly use your tongue
and I was like oh my God thank you for
the tip so I proceeded to place my
tongue somewhere I can only describe as
textually unsettling I have the texture
of like a flan like a tres leches cake
very moist very spongy but it tastes
like a bag of nipples and I was like oh
my god okay oh my god aah aah but I
couldn't tell her that cuz I'm still in
the closet so I was just like oh my god
I'm so full I can't have another bite
you